[Music]
[Applause]
rice is an important staple of Southeast
Asian diets if you need a primer have
different variety they use their own
farm safety which is you don't know the
name we just call from one to another
farmer what duration more than hundred
days so far more can just only one cycle
cambodia has relied on a few traditional
varieties to take longer to mature to
improve yields the international rice
research institute or Erie has developed
a new variety for convenient armors this
race has been engineered to withstand
droughts
additionally it's shorter growth cycle
means farmers can plant and harvest
three times in growing season improving
output by 33%
I hope so it is the cop15 right key we
use the soft curation right key
and it's all its agent at us and it's
home above our three months well new
breakout rapidly dementedly high the
volatility figure find out insects haha
so it is a very good buy T because it's
not
you know it's a foot with those it's
none further protected to which human
deities can grow any time of the year
and also its types or duration and so
that we can save a lot of water in in
the Mekong River dirt Delta which is the
major rice producing area ninety percent
of what what is producing that region is
exported and this is exported to
Philippines Indonesia and to African
countries many of the writers writes
importing countries so it's very that's
why it's been its role in the regional
food security in Southeast Asia is very
important if something happens in that
region many countries will be affected
when it comes to food security rice
farmer income has increased by fifty
five percent a significant benefit for
Cambodians women farmers we are working
to promote the rice variety which is
mainly stressed torrential the drought
flap and also pest problems
and usually the variety that induced by
farmer which is very long duration and
low year and also the quality is not so
good but the variety that we are just
recently released it's very very good
and also very short duration and farmer
has very willing to get it it was
obviously the crop very much tolerant to
drought and especially also to the any
pest problem life from plant hopper
innovations like this are helping
farmers earn more income and see their
families and important steps to reducing
poverty and improving food security
you
[Music]